well let's start at the very beginning
Where it All Began American Idol yeah
what do you remember about that audition
what I remember is that I went in there
singing a Michael Jackson song yeah and
the judges kind of looked at me like
they weren't sure about it they weren't
really feeling it and so I was like I'm
not leaving here without you know
getting through so I was like well okay
well I can sing something else what else
do you guys want to hear and they were
like what else do you have and I said
Bohemian Rhapsody by Queen and you know
if I hadn't have picked that I don't
know if the past decade would have
looked like how it looked it's it's kind
of one of those fate things where you
know you have to give fate sometimes a
little nudge but something stepped in
and and and took care of me oh they gave
me the chills yeah yeah what do you
remember most about that time in your
life
you know it was an interesting time
because I was 27 and I had been doing
Theater in LA but I had slowly started
kind of like fantasizing about like oh I
want to be an artist I want to do this
like outside of theater I want to make
my own music I want to write my own
music and so I started you know writing
stuff I had a band for a little while
but at that point it was such a fantasy
um but I had gotten to a point right
before I auditioned where I was like you
know what I gotta believe in all these
dreams and I got to say yes to
everything yeah and so that's what I did
I went for it because I went for
everything at that point I had I had an
experience out at Burning Man where it
was very inspirational and I was like oh
you know what I need to like dive into
things more and and that's what happened
what advice would you give to your
younger self if you could go back to
that moment
well that was the that was a really
beautiful point because I had made that
decision what I managed to do was I was
not scared anymore for some reason I had
found like sort of that that way of
getting rid of all the fear yeah and and
the self-sabotage and all the things
that come up for a lot of creatives you
know we were all we're all like you know
Our Own Worst Enemy in in certain
moments so somehow I just kind of talked
myself out of being scared of things and
um I thought that fear was the thing
that had held me back for for the the
years before that so I think to any
young person including myself I would
just say like you gotta figure out a way
to face your fear figure it out think
about it meditate on it whatever it is
like find out what it is that you're
scared of and why and and and tackle it
yeah
runner up
was that the best thing that could have
happened
I you know I think either way it would
have been a cute little situation I mean
it was great because it you know right
as soon as the show's over I get offered
a record deal
um I Pro I would have gotten the same
offer I think had I won or had I not won
um which was very cool and you know I
think the only thing that happened was I
didn't have the title you know before my
name but at that point the way the show
worked at that point was they would pick
who they wanted to pick and sign us so I
was really I was just thrilled that I
got a record deal I was like okay this
is the beginning of something great if
you had to do a duet with one judge past
or present who would you pick and why
whoo I want to hear Simon sing just
gonna say what about science because I
bet he can't
um I bet Randy would be really fun but
it's got to be Paula you know she's like
I love Paula or Mariah Carey oh yeah she
was a judge after my time but yeah that
would be yeah that would be good Nicki
Minaj that would that's true a lot of
Judges God the two of them they were
they were I see towards each other
I couldn't stop watching I want more of
it I want more of it Simon would be fun
just because I would love for the rules
to be reversed and you'd be like honey
yeah itchy yeah I would love to I would
love to give Marie yeah but I love Simon
I know he is good we have to talk about
your fashion because you're such a
Showman
thanks okay you you go for it honey you
take risks if we're gonna talk about it
let's let's look at these wrists now I I
don't really like being like blending in
as I'm sure you can tell so you know if
it's extra I want to wear it oh I like
that yeah I need to have that yeah it's
I'm like let's see that okay oh I
haven't looked at them yet
okay look
I'm so glad I didn't wear that jacket
today I was thinking about it where are
you
you die what can you tell us about this
moment well that's the worst angle ever
who ever took that picture that we
crouched on the ground um but other than
that I love that jacket I love that
color it's one of my favorite colors I
think the angle is giving I look boxy
what I do not think you look boxy anyway
first of all don't talk about yourself
you know I'm you know someone has to
okay fair enough but yeah if we I love
that jacket I love that color it's one
of my favorite colors it's gorgeous it
looks so good on you thank you oh my
goodness okay this way
oh yeah that's a good one oh oh God oh
God May Day okay we're back
zooming okay
what is going on I don't remember where
I found that but it was when I when I
found it I was like oh this is it you
bought this yeah I buy most I like I do
a lot of my own putting myself together
how do you have this I just like it I
like it um online shopping is a miracle
and an addiction oh my God I I found
that and but I did find that in a store
and that was in Australia and it was
really hot down there because it was
summer yeah and that was really great
because it was like light cotton and the
Zips under the arms opened up all the
way so it was like air conditioned and
the pants were very tight
huh very tight
okay oh honey oh wow that's a throwback
I was so excited to be at the Grammys I
was nominated that year which I I
remember when I got the call and they
were like you're nominated for a Grammy
for vocal performance I said well what I
couldn't believe it
um
and yeah putting together the outfit I
would work with a stylist at that point
and they were great and yeah I was just
jazzed to be on the red carpet of the
Grammys nervous yeah a little bit Yeah I
think the first couple years of my
career after Idol I was just sort of
deer in the headlights although you know
I put enough eyeliner on that you
couldn't tell
um I I just I felt overwhelmed at times
but also very excited and and lucky
um and grateful to be doing it
um but still trying to kind of find my
footing you know and that's what I'm so
grateful for over the past couple years
um pandemic was you know obviously weird
but it was a great time to kind of
reflect
and kind of get back down to earth and I
just feel like it's nice to know who you
are it's so nice to know especially in
this noisy World absolutely it's really
nice yeah I feel like you knew faster
than all of us but oh snap crackle
no no
[Music]
there were now okay there were times
along the road that I thought something
looked good because this was in the
beginning this is like the first red
carpet I did so you know in my mirror in
my little apartment that looked better
than it actually looked on the carpet
this is interesting but but the cool
thing was is that that shirt matched the
background that was you know wow
coordinated well that is the last of our
looks well thank you for taking me down
memory lane I love it yeah this one it
was this one for me but at least you
were still still authentically you
there's still elements of you in this
even though you've evolved oh yeah that
was definitely that's the me that I
think everybody met you know yeah on TV
imagine you looked completely different
from this and we're like going back to
like oh this was it's totally different
person oh that hair you were still
authentically you since day one well
thanks period I try